an der vernissage im zürcher kunstraum
rhenium finden die besucher zwei objekte
nur es sind platzhalter platzhalter für
die eigentlichen exponate
die stehen dort wo diese gegenstände
sonst sind in wohnungen
nein
die mieter wie stephan rombach
beteiligen sich an einem projekt das die
öffentliche sphäre einer
kunstausstellung auf die privatsphäre
ausweitet so spannend wie dann blüht
normale museumsgänger funktioniert für
stefan bacher haben wir uns entschieden
gegen seines platz halters aus der
wohnung eine fast versteckte fotografie
wer wissen will was stattdessen bei ihm
zuhause ausgestellt wird muss zu
teilnehmerliste und telefon greifen
don't talk to strangers nennt sich das
projekt ein motto voller ironie denn mit
fremden muss man zwangsläufig sprechen
nur durch persönliche kontaktaufnahme
erfahren die besucher wohin sie gehen
müssen um die kunstwerke zu besichtigen
die ausstellung verteilt sich auf zehn
wohnungen in jeder hat ein anderer
künstler gewirkt so wird kunst aus dem
öffentlichen raum ins private überführt
und durch die besucher wieder öffentlich
gemacht gastgeber künstler und
interessierte teilen sich ein
kunsterlebnis bei stefan bacher teilt
man sich vor allem den umfunktionierten
esstisch und damit elemente des
kunstwerks denn dieses besteht aus den
verteilten grünen flächen
sie sind neu in der stube die flächen
gemalt hat für der ricoh erreger der
costa ricaner ist mit seiner abstrakten
kunst weltweit
er wirkt gerne im öffentlichen raum
diesen findet er hier im privaten vor
das hat ihn gereizt die idee des spiels
war sehr wichtig um eine gewisse
bewegung zu kriegen und auch interaktion
das ergänzt sich mit der idee das werk
in einzelteile aufzubrechen
daraus entsteht eine verbindende dynamik
ein streifzug durch die diversen
wohnungen zeigt ob das exponat am boden
liegt oder die wand beschriftet das
private leben wird mit ausgestellt was
die juristische frage erlaubt ist die
eingefärbte bettwäsche spannende oder
der blick ins schlafzimmer
so oder so das ungezwungene umfeld soll
helfen auch kunst fernes publikum zu
gewinnen ist passiert und sage wenn wie
heiko dann wird sich herausstellen ob
das experiment dort funktioniert wo es
stattfindet im alltag
die bewährungsprobe läuft noch bis
dienstag 17
februar